bonjour je me présente je m'appelle
jérôme chagnoux je viens du tampon je
suis d'origine mauricienne et je fais la
cuisine mauricienne la cuisine
authentique de l'île maurice
voilà j'ai un petit restaurant à au
tampon à 438 uba de lille que voilà ça
fait depuis un an maintenant que je suis
d'activité je me suis présenté au coût
de challans de créateurs dans le pa
catégorie innovation et voilà j'espère
d'être parmi les 12
pourquoi pas et agrandir ma société
pourquoi pas à monter une sur saint
denis où la possession
parce que il ya beaucoup de gens de
toute l'île qui viennent chez nous pour
goûter notamment le d'alpuri le faratas
avec le bim die de tous acquis enfin
j'ai un g1 site une page facebook que
vous pouvez voir avec toutes les photos
tout ce que je présente parce que toute
ma cuisine que je fais quoi l'innovation
c'est que il ya qu' il ya que moi qui
fais ça à la réunion les préparations
c'est typiquement mauricienne c'est des
trucs que vous trouvez dans des petits
restos coin de la rue et tout et moi
j'ai décidé d'emmener sa sur les grandes
tables et faire découvrir sa au peuple
réunionnais et si vous venez dans mon
resto il ya aussi l'ambiance de la
musique s'est garé tout avec une petite
sauce à l'ail piment fait maison tout
les petits trucs fait maison voilà